For this first one you have four pieces that are shaded out of sixteen total.
four sixteenths is the same as 1 4ths. I can think about moving these three
pieces over into this region. I move this one here, this one here and this one
here, I'll get one triangle just like I have over here. This is what it would
look like. For the circles, I have two out of three circles shaded. So 2 3rds.
On this side, I have one, two, three, four, five, six pieces shaded, out of
three, six, nine. So I know 2 3rds is the same as 6 9ths. I could also think
about moving this piece over here and moving this piece over here, and I'd have
two full circles shaded and one circle left empty. It would look like this. Okay
on this one, I know I have two pieces shaded out of six, here I have four pieces
shaded out of twelve I know two sixths is the same thing as 4 12ths I can think
about shading this piece and moving it here, this one here and this one here.
That way I'd have 2 6ths and 4 12ths What's also interesting is that both 2 6ths
and 4 12ths is really 1 out of 3, or 1 3rd, these are all equivalent fractions.
For the last one I have 3 out of 7 pieces and in this last one I have 6 out of
14 pieces. So 3 7ths is the same as 6 14ths. Nice work on that quiz.